hi I'm Erik Bosse in this unending wait
period between Avengers movies has been
a sort of year of magical thinking for
people like me surely not to all the
people who ate it an infinity war are
gonna stay dead
right right we've even been getting more
and more clues that that probably won't
be the case one character I want to
focus on is vision his death by the
hands of Thanos at the end of infinity
war was one of the most visceral ones in
many ways the whole goal of this movie
for the Avengers was to protect
divisions life the whole defense of
Wakanda from Thanos his forces was
really a stalling game so to see them
fail like that for vision to be looking
Thanos in the eyes hopeless as the mad
Titan sidelines is instead directed
upwards at the last infinity stone
wedged up in visions forehead and then
retainers to prize fingers into him and
rip it out like a kid yanking a prize
toy out of a box of Froot Loops
it hurts but is there any chance that
this didn't mess up vision as much as it
appears to could he still be alive well
let's look back at our vision was
created because he's kind of an Android
not unlike nebula and you can definitely
take apart that take her toy a whole
bunch without killing her I am sorry
nebula I know it wasn't exactly a
massage for you in age of Ultron vision
was a product of a few different
ingredients first Ultron Ultron wanted
to build a new Android body for himself
but he got interrupted during that
process so visions body is a mix of
vibranium atoms and living human tissue
but when Tony Stark and Bruce Banner got
their hands on this Android body they
replaced
Ultron's interface with that of Jarvis
so vision has the knowledge the inside
the general peaceful nature of Tony
Stark's AI buddy along with Paul Bettany
silky smooth voice but the third
component and arguably the most
important is the mind stone that magical
God rock is the special sauce that makes
vision possible the stone contains a
cosmic supreme artificial intelligence
that powers the whole operation now the
question posed an infinity war was is
there a way to extract visions mind
stone without killing him how vital of
an organ is it when they brought vision
to Wakanda Shuri seemed to figure out a
way forward extraction has put a movie
right we had to attach each neuron
non-sequential ooh why didn't you just
reprogram the synapses to work
collectively because we didn't think of
it I don't know what that mumbo-jumbo
means other than Cherie as wickets
shuri says she can handle this procedure
and this is basically how it works she
would reconnect all of visions neurons
those are nerve cells that cause your
nervous system to work reconnect it in a
way to bypass the Infinity stone so that
instead of the neurons deriving their
electrical signals from the stone these
vibranium infused nerve cells can be
reprogrammed to respond to their own
electrical signals because these nerve
cells are infused with vibranium they
can be reprogrammed the way vibranium
atoms are to respond to their own
electrical current the way that Shuri
programs all of her vibranium particle
suits to respond to each other by
Panthers sue doesn't need a central
Infinity stone power source my premium
is just basically magic you can add it
morph into whatever you wanted to
including Sheree hopes an independent
body for a vision to live in so in order
to do this Sheree would have to detach
the synapses one by one that banner and
star connected to the stone in the age
of Ultron and she warned this would take
a while because we're talking about over
two trillion total neurons being
affected by this
so actually in this scene you can see
her kimono beads projected a hologram of
the mind stone with eight main artery
like neuron threads stemming out from
the stone you can actually see those
same eight stems later when Sheree is
operating on vision using remote lasers
to sever these connections and reattach
them in her holo display you can make
out little strands on her fingers as if
she's a spider reaching into a web and
reconnecting the strands of the web to
each other later during the battle
Corvus glaive breaks into the lab and if
you look closely you can see that Sheree
has made some progress the stone now has
only six neuron stems she rushes her
work further in this panic and she's
attaches a few more main stems leaving
only two remaining by the time she
swipes payal clothes and buyers back at
Corbett's so that means the stone is
still connected to vision when he leaves
the lab but only 25% so so that might
explain why he seems to lose the ability
that phase shift when he's outside
you know how in the past he could become
a projection and have attacks passed
through him doesn't look like he could
do that anymore but this one brings us
to the question what part of vision is
really vision it's kind of like that
age-old question of what part of your
body contains your soul is it your brain
your heart I know mines in my tummy
eating burrito bowls is kind of a
religious experience but what a vision
isn't the Android body or even Jarvis
despite having his voice and personality
what a vision is
pained in the mine stone itself and it
was crucial for sheree not to complete
her detachment surgery and for Thanos to
be able to rewind time and reassemble
the mine stone after Wanda shattered it
because this is actually vision Sol when
Thanos plucked that thing out vision
turned gray and lifeless and we assumed
that he had died but maybe instead of
his death we were actually witnessing
his soul transferring from his Android
body to Thanos his gauntlet now if you
look all over the internet you can find
some theories out there that the mine
stone is the secret evil mastermind
behind all of these events like it's a
stone that veiners had before the other
ones and it manipulated all the Avengers
against each other
hell if you really want to dig into this
you can find some people saying that
Doctor Strange knew all this and gate
they own us the time stone so that he
could save the mind stone and visions
life I don't know if I agree with all
that but I do think that more of visions
essence is stored in that mind stone
than we've realized because he's not
just Jarvis not like Sheree and star can
just reapply Jarvis's interface to
visions corpse and reboot him it's not
that simple but earlier an infinity war
Red Skull reminded us that the stones
carry with them some mysterious wisdom
in the way that US confronted Gamora
inside soul world of the soul stone what
visions presence clings to the mind
stone as another curse haunting Bannos
from beyond the grave like wouldn't it
be interesting if all the stones contain
these kind of spiritual curses in the
form of infinity wars victims the space
stone could possess Loki's ghost the
time stone dr. Strange's ghost the power
stone may be the guardians go since you
know they were kind of linked with it
before in the reality stone maybe
someone from the past of tighten that
Panos teased with the reality stone like
there's his mother suisse on or his
father 'large
I know I'm getting carried away but the
more I think about dr. Strange's overall
plan in this movie which I talked about
at length I just know that phantoms
getting ahold of all six stones and then
being attacked is necessary it must lead
to his defeat somehow and I think the
way that the mind stone proved to be a
more dangerous presence than a
benevolent one and past Avengers movies
I think banished his own completed
gauntlet could be exactly what does men
comment down below with your thoughts on
this theory on where vision could be and
follow the new rock stars on Twitter and
Instagram at new rock stars and for my
own odd takes on life love and burrito
bowls follow me on Twitter and it's the
and of course subscribe to this channel
new rock stars more breakdowns of
everything you love in the meantime I'm
gonna try to pry visions soul out of
this thing we got Paul Benton
[Music]